- Motion for some arbitration
to determine whether or not that is sad
- Motion accepted all in favor.
- [All] I
(lawyer laughs)
- Motion passed Dee
- I'd also like.
- (laughing) Even the
arbitrator voted for the motion.
That's fantastic. Amazing.
(Light hearted music)
I've reacted to,
it's always sunny in Philadelphia twice,
but the fans were very specific.
They wanted one more reaction
and they were very vocal about
which particular episode.
So I put on my weirdest suit
and lets react to it's
always sunny in Philadelphia
Hero or hate crime.
- Oh man. Look at this, dog (beep).
(squish)
- Did you just step in that on purpose?
- No, I just, you know,
I didn't really see it.
- You point it out to me.
- I was just going to ahhhh.
- Is that a lottery scratcher?
(Gears squeaking)
- Who hoist a piano like
a old timey cartoon?
- Look out (beep)
(tense music)
(crash)
- Holy (beep)
What the hell was that?
- What I saved your life.
- But you called me the F word.
- So what, I'm a hero.
- You lose the slur, dude.
That's like a hate crime.
- Yeah, that's hateful speech, man.
- He saved his life.
- You really can't say that.
So which isn't.
(uplifting music)
- So Danny DeVito has saved Mack's life
by yelling out a
homophobic slur at the same time.
And I guess the gang
is going to figure out
if he's a hero or if a hate crime
has been committed.
All right. I'm on board.
Let's find out.
(uplifting music)
(arguing)
- You are entitled to nothing.
Listen motion to present
articles of Confederation.
- Motion denied.
- Oh, shut up (beep).
You don't deserve anything.
- Excuse me.
Hey, can I help you?
- Okay. Look.
Well, usually we're
pretty reasonable crew.
Yeah. Right?
I mean, we have our differences,
but we settle them in house short process.
There's filibusters. The whole thing.
- Okay. Are they a reasonable crew?
I've never gotten that impression before.
Filibusters, I believe.
- This ones a doozy.
- Yeah. This one we can't do in house.
- That's why I want it to
bring in a third party.
Someone to hear us out and
deliver a final verdict.
- That's you guy.
- It is a great injustice has occurred.
- Okay.
They went to arbitration.
- A hate crime.
- I saved your life.
But you use a slur.
- It was slur.
- You'd be dead if I didn't.
- Okay okay . I think I'm getting it.
You want me to figure out
whether or not a hate crime has
been committed?
- What?
- No
- Way off.
- I mean, that's good because
there is definitely no hate crime here.
We'll probably talk about that more.
I'm guessing later on.
- Yeah, No it's about that at all.
- Its about this.
(tense music)
A $2 scratcher lottery ticket.
- Yeah!
- You've hired an arbitration attorney
to figure out which of you is entitled to
a $2 scratcher.
- Now you are getting it. He's getting it.
- [Group] He's getting it.
- The thing is...
- Okay. So this is great.
They went to arbitration.
Arbitration is a thing that you can do.
You don't have to go to court.
If you have an issue that
would normally be
adjudicated by the courts,
you can by agreement with another party.
Agree to take it to a neutral third party
an arbitrator and have
everything arbitrated.
The arbitration basically carries
the force of law.
So the advantages of arbitration
are that you can basically
make up whatever rules that you want.
It's usually much faster,
but it can be more expensive
because the state isn't
paying for the judge.
You have to actually pay
for the judge, the arbitrators time.
So there's pros and cons.
- Each one of us feels that
we're entitled to that ticket.
We need you to tell us who belongs to .
- Why don't you scratch it
and see if it's worthless
and then you wouldn't
have to go through all of this.
- Okay? So he's not getting it.
- What?
(lawyer laughs)
- Hold on
- Okay? Yeah.
- Yeah so look, it doesn't matter
that the scratcher might
not be worth anything.
You could arbitrate, whatever you want.
You just have to pay for
the arbitrators time.
It's completely up to you. So, so far,
this is actually much more realistic
than the prior examples
on it's always sunny
because basically anything
goes in arbitration.
- This ticket represents
hope, Okay potential.
Yeah.
Promise the very foundation
upon which this group rests
- and that hope belongs to me.
- It belongs to me you son of a (beep).
(group arguing)
- Please stop!
Each of you will have an opportunity
to plead your case.
The only rule I have is that you each
treat each other with
respect and common courtesy.
Do we all agree to those terms?
(bell rings)
- Ha Ha Ha
That's incredible.(laughing)
So in arbitration,
because everything is
done by mutual consent,
the parties do have to
agree to the arbitrator.
So if you're not happy
with the arbitrator that
you would normally get,
then you can keep going until
you find an arbitrator
that everyone agrees on.
So it's absolutely hysterical
that the one rule that
everyone treat each other
with compassion and respect,
that's a deal breaker for the gang.
Perfect. A-plus love it.
- I'd like to thank you so
much for taking our case
so last minute.
- The other guy was not
our style. (bike bell ring)
- Yeah well I'm very happy to do so.
I do have a few questions.
- Fire away.
- [Group] Of course. Yeah.
- Now the ticket in question.
Oh, who purchased it?
- Me, thank you. That was me.
And that's why this whole
thing is so cut and dry.
Hold on, I purchased the ticket
and therefore the ticket belongs to me.
I actually bought the ticket
a couple of weeks ago,
but I didn't realize it was going to be so
got (beep) blustery that afternoon.
(wind blowing)
- Yeah, so I actually
think this is probably
pretty cut and dry Dee
purchase the ticket.
It came out of her purse
for just a few seconds.
Really, the only argument against it is
if she abandoned the ticket,
but that's a pretty high standard to make.
It requires an overt act
that clearly shows the owner has
relinquished control.
And the owner has actually intend
to get rid of an abandoned said thing.
And then basically
any third party can come and take the
thing that has been abandoned.
We're talking about losing
a scratcher ticket for
just a couple of seconds.
When the wind blows it away,
there's absolutely nothing
that she did that shows an
affirmative act to abandon
the scratcher ticket.
I think this one is pretty cut and dry,
but at least with respect
to the ownership of the ticket.
Whether there's a hate crime or not,
I guess that's a separate issue.
- The ticket flew out
and landed on the ground.
- So you purchased a ticket two weeks ago.
- I did.
- and why hadn't you
scratched the ticket yet?
- Oh well that's because
nobody ever wins those tickets.
Right. But as long as
you don't scratch it,
then you're not a loser. You know?
In fact you're a winner, potentially.
- Oh God Dee.
- That is so Sad.
- That's so pathetic.
- God that is really so sad, Dee.
That is, that's so sad of her to say. Jeez
- That's the exact same thing
like 10 minutes ago.
Talking about how the ticket represented
hope and all that bull(beep).
- No, that's totally different.
Totally different.
- Motion for sub arbitration
to determine whether or not that's sad.
- Motion accepted all in favor.
- [Group] Aye
(lawyer laughs)
- I also like.
- Even the arbitrator
voted for the motion.
That's fantastic, amazing.
- Well Dee's version is the truth.
It's not the whole truth.
Why don't we talk about
the contents of Dee's purse,
the scratcher ticket,
the candy sour worms,
the pack of cigarettes.
Now, what I want to know is
how could a woman who makes less than
minimum wage afford such impulse buys?
(intense music)
- So you're smoking now Dee?
- How can you actually afford to smoke?
You see Dee and I had a deal,
I give her money for coffee
every morning on the way to work.
She's instructed to give
a very generous tip to
the cashier, Cassie.
(Register sound)
This is from my boss, Dennis.
This establishes both
generosity and authority.
- Oh Okay.
So the argument is that
Dennis is her boss,
and because of the
employment relationship,
it's outside of the
scope of her employment
to have purchased the scratcher ticket.
That is interesting.
Okay. So that, that might work.
So that's a tough one though,
because is it really within
the scope of her
employment to tip the woman
that works behind the counter there?
You can imagine that if your boss
gives you money for,
I don't know, petty cash
for lunch, and then you,
you go out and buy alcohol.
That seems like it's outside
the scope of your employment.
And theoretically, your
employer could then Sue you
for the balance that was misappropriated
by the employee. That one's interesting.
Now wait a minute. Okay.
So there's a really interesting
wrinkle here in that,
even if Dennis is right.
That's outside the scope
of Dee's employment
and that she owes him
damages as a result of that,
the remedy here is probably
not specific performance.
Specific performance, is where you
have to turn over the actual thing.
You see this in real estate,
a lot where a house
or a piece of land is considered unique.
So if there's a breach of contract,
you have to turn over the piece of land.
Whereas in almost all of American law,
the remedy is usually
damages in the form of money.
So here you could argue that
even if Dennis is right,
he doesn't get possession of the ticket.
He gets compensation
for the amount of the Dee should have
been spending on the tip rather than the,
the lottery ticket.
So I don't think he would be entitled
to the ticket or the
funds from the ticket.
If the ticket is worth something.
That is, that is a very complicated
legal issue to think about,
in just the first 10 minutes of this show.
This is fantastic.
- Possibly a little dominance,
it's all very choreographed dance
between two soon to be lovers.
- [Group] Ohhhhhhh
- Cassie is under age.
- [Group] Uggggghhhhhh
- What are you talking about?
Cassie is not under rage.
Cassie is 21 years old.
So the champagne I was purchasing.
- I mean the age of consent
is generally 18 in some
states it's less than that.
So under age, not in a legal sense,
but sort of in a moral sense.
That like this guy who's over 40,
shouldn't be harping on
someone who just turned 21
or is about to turn 21.
That's kind of gross.
- Dee has no rightful
claim to that ticket.
And I'll prove it.
(chimes)
See yesterday
after noticing the contents of her purse,
I decided to follow her this morning.
Cassie never gets her tip.
Does she Dee?
- No, because I refuse to tip for coffee,
I think it's dumb.
- Uh huh
So if you were buying circus peanuts
and candy sour worms and cigarettes,
I think we all know what that means
about the ticket in question. Don't we?
(intense mood music)
- I don't do, you know?
- No.
- Totally lost.
- That means she bought it with my money.
So technically that ticket is mine.
- Okay, Okay, Okay.
- Yeah. I don't think so.
He might have a claim for reimbursement.
I don't think he has any
rightful claim to the ticket itself.
Also, you know, it was a
$2 scratcher who cares,
but I know I'm sure they'll accuse me
of not getting it either.
- Let me sum up the facts thus far,
Ms. Reynolds bought the ticket with
Mr. Reynolds money, but Mr.
MacDonald currently possess it.
- Correct, but I deserve it.
And here's why.
- Okay.
So the law says nothing
about who deserves what
it's about compensating
people for past wrongs.
I don't (laughs)
Look, Charlie is not a legal
expert, even in bird law.
So....
- Filibuster,
- Do you, do you know
what that word means?
- Yep
- What's that mean?
(Charlie yells)
(Door crashes)
- I don't think this
argument is going to work,
but let's, let's hear him out here.
(upbeat music)
- There we were, right.
We were just walking down
the street, our own business.
I just spotted the perfect
pile of dog (beep).
And naturally I step in it.
- What does it doesn't matter anyway.
Because I deserved the ticket
because of the (beep)shoes,
that match her, Charlie gets scratcher.
- What the (beep)
- But look, if it smells
(beep) like you must acquit.
- You know what,
if everyone's going to
be smoking em right now?
(lawyer laughs)
- I mean, all right.
As expected, complete legal insanity.
Though, I do like the
references, Johnnie Cochran, man,
Charlie is just the,
the legal clown that keeps giving it's.
The writers of the show
must know what they're doing
to write Charlie's so insane
from a legal perspective.
it's just, it's wonderful to watch.
- Look, nobody is debating
whether or not the shoe print is yours.
- I mean, can they, can
they actually smoke indoors?
I can't imagine that that
is legal in Philadelphia.
So I imagine that this is
probably, you know, laws broken.
- We all know that it is
because everybody saw you kick me.
We're debating whether or not
you actually saved my life,
which you did not,
because I was just about to do
a sweet back flip to safety.
- Oh bull(beep).
- He has never once flipped.
- I do all the time!
(all yelling at the same time)
- Which you would not have done
if I had not warned you.
Thereby saving your life.
That is my ticket.
(arbitrator sighs)
- Okay. I don't, I don't get it.
Even Frank did save his life.
Why would he be entitled to the ticket?
Just general morality that
if you save someone's life,
you're entitled to something from them.
That's I think that's
going to be dumber than,
than Charlie's argument.
- The point is that I
said, look out (beep).
Which were the words
that saved Mack's life.
Thereby I am entitled to at
least half that ticket that.
- That is complete nonsense.
Whether the slurs used or not,
it doesn't make any sense.
Well, why did you use the slur?
Instead of just yelling
your friend's name?
- There was a lot going on.
- Its irrelevant!
- I needed something
that would cut through.
- Well still, still its irrelevant.
- Everybody knew to look at Mac.
- Okay. It may have been effective,
but it was an offensive slur and a bigot
should not be entitled to a hero's payout.
- You're allowed to use
any language you want
to save somebody's life.
- I mean, okay, this is
completely off the rails,
but I have news for the whole gang here.
You're allowed to use
whatever language you want,
almost all of the time.
There are only a few exceptions
to the first amendment.
None of which apply here.
And we often talk about hate speech
or hate crimes,
but there's no cause of action
that something in and of itself,
just a word itself is hate speech.
And therefore it must be punished.
Now, a lot of people disagree with that.
They think that hate speech
or slurs or particularly
offensive language should be illegal.
Now where you fall in
that particular debate,
doesn't matter because we
have the first amendment.
And as long as we have
the first amendment,
it's going to protect people,
being able to say things like that.
So for the most part,
the definition of a hate crime is
something that is an actual crime,
but it's enhanced because
of the particular racial
or sexual motivation
that is associated with
that particular crime.
That is a crime apart from
whatever words are used.
So this is not a situation
where there is any kind of hate crime,
because hate crimes don't
apply to just mere words.
- Really, any language.
- Yeah
- So let a man die over a word?
- Come on. It's just a word.
- Just a word. Oh, okay.
Well Frank, tell me something.
If you were going to say
somebody else's life,
you know, from a falling piano
and you needed a word to,
just to just cut right through,
what word would you use to
call out to the arbiter?
- He means arbitrator, (laughs)
but good luck with that one, Frank.
- Ugg I suppose.
(light uplifting music)
(rewind sound)
- Okay. Let's ugh
let's just move on.
- Well um
I think we've seen enough.
I've certainly learned
something.(lawyer laughs)
This, this has nothing
to do with being gay.
This is just the work of a man
who's an extreme sexual deviant.
Gay or not.
- Can I have one of those?
- Yeah, Whatever dude,
- Oh whatever.
- You guys are just jealous
Because I've got a million dollar idea
and I've got the ticket.
- Okay, he has the ticket.
I don't think he has a
legal claim to the ticket.
I also don't think that's
a million dollar idea.
(Lawyer laughs)
Oh no, and okay.
So theoretically,
what does Dee do if she
has a claim to the ticket
and Mac doesn't want to relinquish it?
She would Sue him for conversion.
- You actually don't believe
in evolution anymore.
- I don't know.
He created a reasonable doubt.
He makes you sound like
a stupid science (beep).
- Effectively civil theft of the thing.
And here since Mack hasn't
paid anything for it,
it's not like the,
the Dennis situation
where Dee was supposed to take
a certain amount of money,
but use it for other purposes.
Dee would then Sue Mac for conversion
and the damages would be the value
of the ticket itself.
So Dee would be entitled
to whatever the ticket
is worth from Mac.
We'd need to scratch the ticket
to find out how much exactly.
But again, she can't Sue
for specific performance
of the ticket itself.
I don't think.
- And I will make my decision,
but let me make one thing clear
in order for this to be entirely just,
I will make my decision based
on fairness and compromise.
- She's, she's getting the boot
(bells rings)
(Lawyer laughs)
- Oh So good.
- So what's the verdict?
- Yeah what have you got?
- So I've never run
into a situation where,
and I participated in many arbitration's
where the parties have midstream
decided to get rid of the arbitrator.
I can't imagine that there's any reason
why you can't do that,
but you can imagine that you're
going to have to start over,
which would be extremely expensive.
So you're not going to
see it all that often,
by the way, arbitrators
are really expensive.
They often are former judges.
And so if an attorney
might be charging $500
an hour in a given area,
which is probably middle of the road
for a big area like LA or New York.
An arbitrator might charge
two or three times that
it's not uncommon for an
arbitrator to charge a thousand
or $1,500 an hour, because
if they are a former judge,
then you know, they're in high demand.
Now you can hire a cheaper arbitrator.
These specifically,
they said that this is
an arbitration attorney
rather than a former judge.
So they're probably not
going to charge that much,
but still, arbitrators are
really, really expensive.
- I think I'm all caught up.
- All right so what's the verdict?
- Yeah what have you got?
- I think it's actually
pretty straightforward.
Mr. McDonald has in
possession of the ticket.
So he has ownership.
- No, absolutely not.
It's an old wives tale
that possession is nine tenths of the law.
Not a thing.
Absolutely, Mac does not get possession
and ownership of this ticket.
No way.
- However, he would not be in possession.
If his life were not
saved by Mr. Reynolds.
Who set off the chain
of events, saving him.
- Totally irrelevant to ownership.
- So I see it as a 50 50 Split.
- What that's it?
- Are you kidding me?
- I'm a hero.
- For putting the man out of the way!
- Nothing for the man...
- Okay. That's completely wrong.
Not based in law whatsoever.
However, arbitrators can
often make any decision
that they want to.
Now, their decision
has to be based in law.
So it's not so much the outcome
that can be challenged here,
but the process by which this arbitrator
came to this decision.
So if she can't back up
this 50, 50 split in law,
which I don't think she can.
Then you would appeal this
decision to the trial court and
eventually to the court of appeal.
Which would be even more expensive
and insane in this particular situation.
So I really liked this episode, but I,
this arbitrator is really
missing the ball on this one.
- Nothing for the man
who paid for the ticket.
- I bought it.
- And this bigot here
is going to get the heroes payout?
- He may be a bigot
and he did use disgusting speech,
but it's not technically hate speech
since Mr. McDonald does
not claim to be gay.
- Uh Oh.
- No, something can be hate speech,
but that has no legal repercussions.
That hate speeches is not something
that's really codified in law.
So it doesn't really work here either way,
but there are no legal
repercussions that come as a result
of whether it is or is not hate speech.
- Oh, does that mean if I claim to be gay
I get all of it?
- Well um, yeah.
Yes. You would be entitled
to keep all of it.
- I claim to be gay.
- [Group] No, no no
- There is a history behind it.
- I have been gay forever
everybody knows it.
Hey, excuse me.
Would you please do the
honors on my ticket please?
- Oh, you're a winner.
- What, how much?
- $10,000.
- Nooooooooooo
(all scream and groan)
- All right.
If you'll just take care of this,
then we'll be all done.
- What's this?
- That would be a bill.
I know it's steep,
but you did go through three arbiters
and you've been here 17 hours.
- Ha Ha
- I'm exhausted
- What does that add up to their?
- 9,986,000.
(lawyer laughing)
- Okay. That is totally reasonable.
17 hours, $9,000.
So a little over $500 an hour.
Yeah, that is that is
honestly right in line
with what I can imagine.
An arbitration attorney
would actually cost.
So that's, that's perfectly realistic.
- Yikes
- Holly cow you guys are paid well,
you guys aren't cheap.
- The arbitration was Max idea.
Let's let him pay.
- That's a great idea.
- That's fair.
And he's got the money for it.
He's got the money now.
- Yeah. Except they all
agreed to it and believe me,
you would sign all kinds of contracts.
Every single one of those
people would be liable for the
costs of the arbitrators because you know,
they want to make sure that they get paid.
All right.
So let's give this episode
of it's always sunny
a grade for legal realism.
(happy music)
On the one hand arbitrators are expensive.
They can set whatever rules they want.
And honestly, this is not the most
unrealistic portrayal of
an arbitration proceeding.
On the other hand,
they're arbitrating over nonsense.
Their legal arguments were
completely insane and the
arbitrator had no bearing
in fact, or law whatsoever.
So overall,
I'm going to give this
episode of it's always sunny,
a B plus, nice job.
Now, if you'd like to listen
to more legal stories,
they're are even more accurate
than it's always sunny.
You should listen to John
Grisham's new legal thriller,
the judges list with
today's sponsor audible.
It's a story of investigator Lacey Stoltz.
As she follows the trail of a
serial killer and closes in on
a shocking suspect, a sitting judge.
He is the most cunning
of all serial killers
because he knows forensics
police procedure.
And most importantly, the law.
Now, honestly, I was going to make a joke
about John Grisham put, frankly,
that sounds pretty awesome.
I'm definitely going to listen to that
because I use audible almost every day.
It's by far the best source
of audio entertainment.
I listen to audio books when
I'm running, cleaning up,
or when I'm supposed to be
listening to friends or loved ones.
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
all in one place.
If you tried to listen to
everything that they have,
it would take three centuries.
And as an audible member,
you'll get one credit every month.
Good for any title in the
entire premium collection,
which includes basically
every bestseller new release or a memoir.
And those titles are yours to keep forever
in your audible library.
You'll also get access to
their popular plus catalog,
which is filled with thousands
and thousands of audio books,
original entertainment,
guided fitness and meditation,
sleep tracks, and shows.
All included with your membership.
No credits required,
and audible is running a
special holiday promo for legal Eagles.
So now is the absolute best
time to join, new members.
We'll get 60% off for
the first three months.
That's only $5.95 a month.
All you have to do is click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description,
or go to audible.com/legaleagle.
So right now, for a limited time,
save 60% on your first three
months of audible by clicking
the link that's on screen.
And while you're at it,
click on this playlist over here
with all of my other real
lawyer reacts videos.
So click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.